and the New York Times looks at why so
many of us are guilty of procrastination
the article says putting off a necessary
project is not about laziness it's a way
of coping with challenging emotions and
negative moods induced by certain tasks
well the writer of that article
Charlotte Lieberman joins us here along
with productivity expert I like that job
Laura van der Cam's she is the author of
the time management fable Juliet school
of possibilities a little story about
the power of priorities good morning to
both of you Charlotte I want to begin
with you why do we procrastinate are we
just pre-wired to do it there there's an
element of evolution that's actually
here which i think is fascinating I mean
basically we're creatures of survival so
if we're given a task whatever it is
might be cleaning a dirty bathroom which
is boring and arduous I might be doing
you know writing an article which is
what I did which I definitely
procrastinated on it induces anxiety it
might induce self-doubt and that those
feelings are uncomfortable so a
researcher I spoke with Tim Mitchell he
said that we all have this inner
six-year-old and the feeling that we
feel is I don't want to do this yeah and
that's I mean that's really profound
emotion and we think of ourselves as
being lazy but I think there's a lot of
comfort to be drawn from the fact that
this is so universal and it's so
illogical right I remember having this
discussion with my daughter sitting at
the end of her bed when she wasn't doing
her homework and explaining I've done
this I can tell you where it ends it's
not and she looked at me and she said
but why did you do it and I said I never
figured that part out right but just
don't but I mean but why is why are you
punishing your future your future self
for the present well because we'd like
to feel good in the present and you know
often as she was saying it is about
anxiety it's really hard to try our best
and still possibly fail at things
whereas if we put something off to the
last minute we know we didn't do our
best
Frank it's a little bit easier on the
ego if we you know don't do our best
work well you are a time management
expert who was once late to your own
time management session that I was
there's a little bit of irony there but
I always think you make time for things
that are important to you is that not
true
it
so true I mean whenever we say I don't
have time we're really saying it's not a
priority yes something is important to
you you will make it happen if somebody
offers you something good that will make
it rise up the priority list I'll also
make it happen well I was joke you know
I don't feel like dusting my blinds but
if somebody offered to pay me a hundred
thousand dollars to dust my blinds I
would figure out a way to give a great
example of you you compare it to a
hot-water heater a broken hot-water
heater
about what how we figure stuff out yeah
well a lady who tracked her time for me
once had a very busy week and then her
water heater breaks and there's water
all over her basement
well she finds seven hours to deal with
this problem if we'd asked her at the
start of the week you know can you find
seven hours to train for a triathlon or
something like that no no way could we
find the time but when you have to so is
it emotional I was interested I was
fascinated by you'd said it's an
emotional thing and that we shouldn't
really beat ourselves up about this I
mean I think those are there tooth
points that you're saying there I mean
the first part is it is emotional and I
think what your question about the
future self I mean that we are creatures
of survival as I said and I think you
know if you're being chased by a tiger
you're not thinking about preparing
dinner that evening you're dealing with
what's right there and that is fear that
is I got to get the heck out of here and
so similarly our we're actually wired to
deal with the present problem so our
brains aren't really thinking like I'm
just dreading cleaning this bathroom
we're thinking like I feel kind of
unsafe right now and I don't want to do
they're wired differently though because
I was just having this conversations my
stepdaughters in college she and her
roommate were both preparing for a test
well my stepdaughter studying throughout
the week the roommate crammed last
minute the night before they both did
very well so are some people just better
at performing under pressure last minute
I think more people think they're better
at performing well under pressure at the
last minute then actually our and and
maybe it can work for a test sometimes
if it what it gets you to tune out
Instagram or all those things like that
but if you're trying to do creative work
for instance leaving it to the last
minute means you probably won't come up
with all the different scenarios you
won't think about what can go wrong
whereas if you leave time to come back
to it then you can do a better job
what's interesting to me is the vicious
cycle that gets created because usually
when you put something off you end up
feeling bad about yourself which makes
you behave badly
like further and it just spirals down
and I remember in that conversation I
have my daughter I said if you just stop
this forgive yourself for for kind of
screwing up it all changes but we did we
still it's so hard to get over that the
self-compassion yeah writing about yeah
yeah I mean there's there thousands and
thousands of studies about this I mean
if we actually take a moment and say you
know I mean I actually do this I put my
hands like on my heart a lot of the time
and I just say you know what it's okay
and if if I were talking to a friend I
wouldn't say you know you're such an
idiot for putting off whatever that's
one recommendation Laura one start small
so take some part of the project that
you feel no resistance to doing you know
you're writing a report maybe it's that
you know you're gonna put one statistic
in the middle just write it down and see
how that feels and probably that wasn't
so bad and maybe there's another quote
you can put in you don't feel so bad
about that and maybe there's something
you think of in the middle and next
thing you know the things have done
you've tricked yourself into it what's
interesting is that it procrastinations
in something you outgrow right you deal
with that throughout your life right
it's a human thing yeah thank you so
much great to have you here thank you so
much